Welcome to the second
lecture about central
nervous system
infection and this one
basically is about
parasites or fungi.
I hope you enjoyed
this lecture. It's
pretty much sounds
like me, it's like a
weirdly believe it
or not because of the
weirdness of some
of these pathogens
involved. So it's
kind of a fun lecture.
Here are the objectives
that we should meet
by the end of lecture
is basically to
describe different types
of fungal and parasitic
central nervous system
infections and the
ideology compare and
contrast parasitic and
fungal meningitis talk
about the properties
of both parasitic and
fungal ideologies uh
what are agents of
meningitis encephalitis
myelitis and brain
abscesses and i'll talk
about the importance
of csf analysis and
antimicrobial therapy
for controlling these
diseases and identifying
them and discuss
the epidemiological
factors that help us
determine the ideology
and just a quick reminder
we already talked
about these the terms
again meningitis is
inflammation of the
meninges several forms
acute exceptic and chronic
our focus in this case
gonna be mostly on
chronic because most
acute meningitis is
bacterial or viral
excepting meningitis we
talked about and the
prior lecture it's mainly
when the culture is
negative, a lot of
that is viral, but it
also can be bacterial.
We also talk about
encephalitis, which
is inflammation
of the brain
parenchyma itself,
myelitis, which
is inflammation
of the spinal
cord, and we'll
talk about
brain abscesses.
Let's talk a little
bit about chronic
meningitis and how
that differs a little
bit from acute. So
again, with chronic
meningitis, you
get inflammation
you may get csf
pleocytosis which you
know over four weeks
that's a prolonged
type of infection
symptoms take days and
weeks they evolve
very different from an
accurate presentation
there may be
headache there may be
fever there may be nodal
rigidity but a lot
of times it's absent
so that cannot be a
determining one it
can progress you can
not get seizures you
may see some mental
status changes,
confusion, hallucinations,
or not. It all
depends on the organism
and the severity.
We may see some
focal neurological
defects developing,
depending on whether
or not there's
particular pressure
in certain areas,
and we may see
hypercephalus or even
increased intracranial
pressure in this
chronic menilitis.
these are the most
common etiological
agents fungal and
parasitic agents of chronic
meningitis we'll
talk about those
aspergillus species
candida coccidiotes
cryptococcus histoplasma
pseudo aldeceria
species sporothrix when
it comes to parasites
the most common ones
are tania solium
and energy strongest
species so we'll talk
about those and
mention some other ones
common things that we
see in fungal chronic
meningitis is mostly
it's an opportunistic
type of infection usually
again by definition
that there's some
sort of a immune
suppression predominantly
a cellular or cell
mediated immune suppression
immune response it
does not really typically
related to humoral
and as we talked
about before humoral
immune response doesn't
seem to actually have
much role in fungal
infections anyway
with fungal chronic
meningitis we
see moderate
lymphocytic pleiocytosis
the first we're going
to talk about is
cryptococcus neophormus
as you know it's
the only capsulated
fungal agent so it's
kind of it's one of a
hallmark as you can see
that on the microscite
there this is
actually an india ink
preparation which is one
of the key laboratory
ways to show you the
presence of capsules
typically the presentation
of cryptococcus
neoformans chronic
angivis presents
as subacute meningitis
sometimes could be
fever unknown urgen
you may also have
hydrocephalus starting
out like that and then
it just evolves into
a chronic meningitis.
Again with lab we
talked about the
india ink another
one too is to watch
out for is or to order
is a cryptococcal
antigen latex
equanimation or latex
basically latex
equanimation test
looking for the
cryptococcal antigen.
Treatment which was
again very common
you'll see apoteriosum
being one of the
most one of the
most common and the
fungal IV drugs very
potent and that's
typically combined
with flu cytosine.
Let's talk about
coccidiodes and
again coccidiodes
there are two different
important species
so dasi and
imetis and that and
these species are
different have different
geographical locations.
Acroxiodis is pretty
much most commonly
presented in the southwest
United States, Arizona,
California, New
Mexico, those regions.
Sea emitters tend
to be more southern
California limited
while sodassi seems to
be the rest of the
southwestern United
States. Usually
presents as erythema as
you can see right
there and also can you
know can show up as
hydrocephalus too.
For lab
CSF egosinophilia is
common but you gotta
keep in mind that a
lot of these diseases
are endemic and so they
may show up anyway.
Another thing to look
for is complement
fixing antibodies that
seem to be common in
75 to 95 percent of
cases so it could help.
Culture can be positive
only in 50% of the
cases, so you'll miss
most of them, and culture
is really hazardous
with coxiodes because
it's highly infectious
and exposes laboratory
personnel to getting
the disease themselves,
so it's not commonly
used or preferred.
And again, as you
notice, the same
treatment, IV and
Pterosin B, and combine
that with some
sort of an azole.
Let's talk about
histoplasmosis
or histoplasma.
Capsulatum is sometimes
called cave disease.
But we're talking
here about chronic
meningitis as a result
of histoplasmosis, not
your typical
histoplasmosis, which is the
more of a respiratory
tract infection.
Again, very rare when
it comes to developing
chronic meningitis
from histoplasmosis.
The organism
itself is endemic
to the Ohio River
Valley regions.
It usually
presents itself,
or chronic meningitis
of histoplasmosis
presents itself as fever.
You may see oral lesion,
hepatospedomegaly,
and hydrocephalus.
For labs results,
basically culture is
you see quite a range
of positivity in
cases so it's not
extremely reliable
looking for the
histoplasma polysaccharide
antigen in the samples
like urine blood it's
seen at 61% of patients
and or you can usually
look at the microscope
and see those yeast
cells inside micro
figures as is shown on
this micrograph on the
right side there that
blood smear so if you
notice none of the lab
tests are indicative
or you know highly
sensitive for this
disease or combination of
what can help along with
the clinical picture
and again if you notice
the treatment is almost
the same like we talked
about with coxioides
and crypto it's
amperteris and BIV so in
a sense none of this
changed the treatment
let's turn attention
to a another ******
known as Pseudoeligeria
boidae Pseudialesuria
boidi is actually one
of the most common
fungal etiological
agents of mysotomas.
Mysotomas are
basically clinical
syndromes that
involve cutaneous and
subcutaneous tissues.
It could also
involve fascia,
joints, and bones.
This organism can
cause meningitis,
can cause
meningioencephalitis, and
even brain abscesses.
It seems to be more
common, most common
immunocompromised
patients, but actually
you can see it
in a few immunocompetent
individuals.
Again, we're
not sure why.
Typically found in
polluted waters, sewage
swamps, so it's
kind of a, you know,
water organism.
Common in
individuals that
basically nearly drowned.
So it seems that
experience
might, you know,
cause enough water
with this organism
to go into their
body and compromise
their immune
response and lead to
chronic meningitis.
So kind of a clue.
This organism seems
to be resistant to
amphotericin B, which
is the classic drug we
use to treat a lot of
systemic fungal infections,
and so myconazole
seems to be another
alternative drug
that shows promise.
But a lot of times, you
know, a lot can
be done. So,
so far we have
discussed fungal chronic
meningitis. We're going
to turn our gears a bit
here and discuss
different parasites that
cause chronic meningitis.
The most common of
them is Tania solnium,
also known as the pork
tapeworm. As you can
see it on the slide on
the right side, there
is the pork tapeworm.
It causes
neurocysticercosis, and as
you can see that on the
MRI, very distinctive,
these regions,
these small dots.
It's endemic in Mexico,
South America and
angio usually the most
common presentation
is seizures but you
also have cysts in the
which in the brain which
cause hydrocephalus
can also result in
space occupying lesions
in the lab typically
CT scan of the head
shows these calcified
lesions as we're
looking at them now
those dots those white
dots also you'll
see lymphocytic
pleiocytosis with
eosinophils or eosinfilia.
Treatment is the drug
known as albendazole.
It's a broad-spectrum
antihelmetric
drug that usually
inhibits tubulin
pulmonization. So it
basically prevents
the cells of the
tapeworm from basically
dividing because it
prohibits tubulin.
Again, and other
supportive drugs
like to reduce
inflammation of
steroids, analgesic
for the pains,
anti-epileptic to prevent
the seizures which
is the most common
presentation and you may
even need surgical
removal of the lesions
and placing a shunt
if you have you know
severe hydrocephalus
especially from those
obstructive cysts now
you can also see like the
eggs of tania there
that's what that happens
a lot of time with
like undercooked meat
Another parasite that
can cause chronic
meningitis is
angiostrongulus cantonensis.
Angiostrongulus
cantonensis, as you can
see right there, it's
a roundworm. It's
usually referred to
as the rat longworm.
It's systemic
again in Asia and
the Pacific Islands.
Typically comes
from ingesting in
raw or not very
well cooked
shellfish or snails.
Really bizarre
incubation period it can
last up to a year
so you can ingest
these things and
not develop anything
for up to a year as
the organism is growing
very slowly inside
the human body.
Typical presentation
you will see
nausea, vomiting,
you can see some
local agility and
headaches that
are typically
global and severe.
Rash with proitis
can be also common.
Diagnosis is usually
based on history,
looking at the area
where the person
came from, the type
of food they eat,
also analyzing CSF
and looking for like
peripheral ursynophilia
would help.
There's really no
treatment for this
for this worm and
typically seems
to resolve
spontaneously over time.
Of course you gotta
treat the nausea at
vomiting just some of
the you know adjunct
symptoms but not
the actual organism.
The rest of these
species right here can
also cause chronic
vangitis but very rare
occasion but I
mentioned it for you
like blastomycosis,
candida species fungal
can cause, paracroxioides
can also cause
philophyomycoses,
mucor, actinomyces,
toxoplasma, sporophyx,
which is the rosebud,
which usually comes
from the garden,
and aspergolus, all
these can actually cause,
but extremely, extremely
rare situations.
So, and they can
also cause abscesses,
which end up looking like
into the subarachnoid
space and which then
end up with, you
know, a presentation
of chronic meningitis
so but just kind
of add to your list
and in case there's
a board question on a
subject like that so
we'll shift a bit and
talk about encephalitis
and of course
encephalitis is the
inflammation of the brain
brain itself this is
usually associated
with evidence of
neurologic dysfunction
it's one of the most
challenging syndromes
to diagnose less
than 50% of the time
you can actually find
a specific pathogen.
The reason for now
there's tons of different
infectious causes that
can happen and they
all have very similar
display of symptoms
and then there's
really not very good
standards in regard
to testing. You
know our molecular
testing better,
our serologic,
which ones are more
reliable, which ones
are more sensitive.
So parasitic forms
of encephalitis tend
to be less commonly
identified, but
they're very neurotropic
and can cause
sporadic encephalitis
and myelitis, so
it's important to
keep an eye on those.
One that's not common,
but you see it from
time to time, even
here in different
locations in the United
States and that is
the organism known
as negleria fowlerii.
Negleria fowlerii
is a protozoan
that actually causes
amoebic meningeoencephalitis
or common referred
to as PAM.
It's basically a brain
eating disease where
you get almost the
structure of the tissue.
100% mortality a
lot of times happen
during swimming
and basically when
from water going
through the nose.
You know, it's common
in the southern
states, that's why
you'll see cases
in Arkansas and
other locations.
It's actually a
thermophile, so it likes
warm temperature
and grows in that.
But again, distinguish
it from the one
that we talked about
where you have a your
drowning experience,
this is different.
With Nycleria phylitis,
you usually see
loss of sense of smell,
altered levels of
consciousness and symptoms
in the lab. You'll
see metrophilic
pleiocytosis. You can
also look under, you
know, take a biopsy of
the brain and look at
brain histopathology.
You can even observe
the trophozoites
of Necleria in a
wet mount from a
freshly drawn CSF.
You can see the
trophozoites on the
right side there and
they're also on the
bottom right side
too. In the center
at the bottom there
is the picture of
the amoeboid mature
basically Necleria and
then on the left side
is the dormant or
cyst form or you know
kind of like an egg you
typically disorder this
happens in the summer
of course because
of people are swimming
and warmer temperatures
seems that children
and adolescent boys
specifically are at
higher risk and usually
swimming in freshwater
and specifically like
water sports seem to
predispose people to
this type of disease
again it's a very very
rare but it does happen
treatment is not much
treatment there's very
high mortality even
with treatment which
is mainly supported
and there's a drug called
Maltifacin it seems
to show promise
Maltifacin has been used
in India for treatment
of Blishmania and it
basically inhibits the
protein kinase part
of the inositol triphosphate
signal transduction
pathway so there
will be some promise
with that and saving
lives. And I think
recently I've heard it's
actually was used, so.
Another cause of
parasitic encephalitis is
the organs known as
Belmuthia mandelaris.
It's a soil
photozoan, it's
typically endemic
in Central America.
You get it from
cuts and wounds
on the skin or inhale it,
especially
inhaling the cysts.
Now you can see
the cysts on the
slide on the
other side and you
can also see the
amipoid version.
Presentation is very
similar to tuberculosis.
It actually forms
granulomatous
amoebic concephilitis.
So granuloma
is very similar
to TB. It's
almost like TB in
an immunocompromised
patient.
Again, you get a sub
-acute progressive
disease with space
-occupying lesions,
cranial nerve palsy can
occur, and hydrocephalus.
A lab usually rely
on serology, but
those are only done
in the research lab
because of the rareness
of the disease.
And you can
also use brain
histopathology, send
them to the path lab.
Prognosis.
Prognosis is very
poor with the Balmuthii.
It's actually a
slow progressive
disease, sometimes
takes up to two years
and almost 90
percent mortality.
In the lab, we can
look for lymphocyte
pleiocytosis and
also depressed
glucose which can
also could use it with
TB because the
picture is so similar.
Indirect
immunophorescent antibody
can be helpful.
Again, we talked about
brain histopathology
and there's
also recently
using nucleic acid
amplification of the
actual brain tissue.
Treatment, self diazine
seems to be helpful
in combination with
like a macrolide
like azithromycin or
clarithromycin. You
can also have perfampin
and fluconazole
and collectively
they seem to to help.
Next one we're
going to talk about
is the raccoon
roundworm and known
as barely scarys
prochognosis.
Again it typically
happens by ingesting
infectious eggs accidental
like dust or dirt
by accident somehow
there's a raccoon that
you know lay feces
and then people
accidentally eat it
um again happens with
individuals that you
know that have pica or
geophagia which is
eating dirt um in the lab
you look for arsenic
pleiocytosis uh also
peripheral areas
nephilia uh deep white
matter abnormalities
and MRIs and serology
can be done on the CSF
or serum but that's
usually in the center
of disease control.
So you have to send
the samples there.
Epidemiology is found
whenever there's
infected raccoons in
like Mid-Atlantic,
Northeastern United
States, Midwest
United States, even
parts of California.
Treatment is basically
using the broad-spectrum
antihelmetic drug
known as albendazole.
Albendazole, as we
talked about it already,
actually inhibits tubulin
polymerization. We
talked about that
in relation to
tania sonium.
Talk about
this roundworm,
the stoma species.
Basically, it happens
in tropical, subtropical
areas like Thailand
and Japan, and it
typically happens from
eating undercooked or
like freshwater waterfish,
eels, frogs, birds,
reptiles, predominantly
undercooked meat.
It's kind of a creepy
one. It actually
can move, you know, go
from digestive tract
and move under the
skin and get all the
way to the brain or
cause encephalitis.
It's diagnosed
microscopically. You can look
at the larvae in the
tissue or you can do
treatment also seems,
albendazole seemed
to work also, ivermectin,
especially for
the skin infection.
Ivermectin recently
has gained a lot of
popularity because of
treatment for COVID
or you know it's been
considered as a,
seemed in some smaller
trials as effective
for COVID treatment.
There don't seem
to be any treatment
for central nervous
system infections.
Let's talk about
brain abscesses from a
fungal and parasitic
perspective, because
we talked about
bacterial brain
abscesses. Remember,
we talked about those
predominantly caused
by staph aureus and
mixed species of
aerobic and anaerobic.
Again, brain abscesses
seem to be two to
three times more common
in males than females.
We don't know why.
More common in young
children and adults
over 60. A lot of
predisposing conditions like
otitis media or
mastitis and spreads to
the brain again as we
talked about before
mostly nectarine
ideology but there's some
parasitic and fungal
cases uh and we have
those listed here
parasites that can cause
brain abscesses we're
here gene isonium um
which is you know sister
surcosis and amoeba
histolytica or just
amoeba sometimes people
call it schistosoma
japonica we'll talk
about those and pragnonium
paragonus species.
Fungi happens
typically in
immunocompromised
patients.
Aspergillus species
in patients that
are black bone marrow
and transplant.
T-cell immunity defects
like AIDS patients
are usually
predisposed to like
cryptococcus brain
abscesses and neutropenia
patients seem to
be predisposed to
Aspergillus mucor and
Candida in
regard to this.
The clinical manifestations
from brain abscess
in typically all those
symptoms from that
is predominantly because
the space occupying
vision and so you'll
see things like 75
percent of regions
have headache, altered
mental status, focal
neurological findings
especially depending on
where the location is,
hemiparesis in
over 60 percent,
fever in 50 percent
of patients,
nausea and vomiting
in 25 to 30.
Seizures, you know,
30% and again other
signs of symptoms
can be present
depending on the
abscess size, the stage
and where it's
located in the brain.
Laboratory findings
you'll see is
beautiful lococytosis but
again the 40%
cases are normal.
Low serum sodium
could be a result
of ADH, antidiuretic
hormone.
Platelet counts may
be either higher low,
you may have elevated
lymphocytes alimentation
rate and also elevated
C-reactive protein
suggesting inflammation.
But if you notice
a lot of these are
none, they're just
general findings which
makes this challenging.
But combined
with the clinical
picture, it could help.
Anti-amoeba histotica,
as we talked about,
it's it typically
causes amoebiasis or
amoebic dysentery, which
is pretty if you have
GI disease or you
have ****** diarrhea.
But it can also cause
brain abscesses.
You can see on the
right side here many of
the trilfosolites ingested
with erythosolites
like inside a red
blood cell or basically
the amoeba have eaten
a lot of the blood.
You can also see
the cyst stained
with trichrome
showing triple
nuclei and
chromated bodies.
and this life cycle
on the right side
diagnosis typically
serology or you can do pcr
of the brain abscess
or csf treatment for
anti-amoeba brain
abscess is metronidazole
which typically
binds dna and blocks
synthesis or tinnidazole
tinnidazole seems to
become converts to like
a nitro radical that
attacks the actual
parasite structures,
and followed by
peromomycin, which is an
aminoglycoside that
inhibits proteasynthesis,
or the drug called
Idoquinol, which
mechanism of action
is currently unknown.
Another cause of
brain abscesses
is schistosomiasis
or schistosoma.
Japonicum is one of
the common species.
Also, this disease
is known as Belharzia
in many parts of the
world. It's a blood
fluke. It's a fluke
form, basically.
Not found in the U
.S., but you can come
if somebody comes to
the United States,
either traveled or
you know immigrants.
And so, a careful
review of the
history and travel
and where the
person has come
from is important.
It's actually quite a
common disease. It's
second in impact after
malaria with over
200 million cases a
year, is considered the
most devastating
parasitic disease in the
world. It lives in
freshwater snails and
actually enters into
the body as people are
walking in freshwater
like ponds or rivers
and so on. The fluke
can enter in between
the toenails, not
the toenails, sorry,
between the toes
basically, just enter right
to the skin, crack the
skin and get inside
the body, which is
very unusual because
most pathogens cannot
********* the skin.
C. japonicum from
the schistosoma is
the mouth pathogenic
species seems to
produce tons of eggs
so when people get
infected they just
keep shedding a
lot of eggs per day
into the environment
which you know
continues the cycle.
Lab results like
microscopic examination of
the eggs, ELISA looking
for anti-schistosomal
antibodies but that
has be careful when
looking in the endemic
area and checking if
there's any granulomas
formed in the brain.
Treatment is using
the drug prazequantil.
Prazequantil basically
it's not clear
how it does it but it
seems to cause spasm
and paralysis of
the actual worms.
People think because
it maybe increases
the influx of calcium
which results in
more muscle contractions
of these worms.
last but not least
talking about
pyraconomous species.
This is a long fluke,
as you can see
it on the right
side. It occurs from
an interesting raw
undercooked either
crab or crayfish.
It's rare in
the U.S., but
there might be
multiple cases like
that happen in
the midwest,
especially like
crayfish on river raft
trips like on the
Missouri River. You hear
somebody like in a
buffet and eating that
kind of stuff and
they end up with this.
Paragonalus
calcuttae seems
to be the most common one
endemic in midwestern and
southern United States
especially in
crayfish. Very
similar symptoms
to tuberculosis.
Same treatment as
cystosomes with
pisequantil
and again very similar
laboratory diagnosis
looking for the eggs
and also looking for
if there's any peripheral
aerosinophilia. So
notice a lot of
aerosinophilia seems to be
common in parasitic
infection. That's because
the aerosinophils,
as you already know,
are a big part
of the immune
system's response
to parasites. To
summarize, we've
talked about different
types of etiology of
fungal and parasitic
central nervous
system infections.
We've compared and
contrasted parasitic
and fungal meningitis,
mostly chronic.
We talked about
the different
properties of parasite
fungal patterns
as it relates
to meningitis,
encephalitis,
mellitis, and myelitis
and brain abscesses.
We've also identified,
talked about how
different CSF analyses
with different ones can
help and what kind of
antimicrobial therapy
is available and
talked about about the
epidemiology that's
important to determining
some of the ideology
of these diseases
whether it happens in
adolescence, whether it
happens in summer
times, from eating raw
cooked meat or locations,
travel history, all
important in diagnosing
a lot of these
diseases. And so, clues
for looking into that
in the history of the
patient and, by default,
you know, exam
questions will help
determine the answers
with the correct answers.